Catherine denuve qu'est-ce qui vous a il
vous a séduit est-ce que c'est le fait
de tourner avec manuel de Olivera avec
qui je crois vous n'aviez jamais
tourné j'avais envie de tourner avec lui
j'avais un certain désir de le connaître
et j'ai eu la possibilité en faisant une
télévision au Portugal il y a pas très
longtemps finalement de pouvoir lui
faire savoir et grâce à Paolo Branco le
producteur qui est le producteur
vraiment de Manuel d' Olivera il a
réussi à mettre en scène très très vite
la la production du film et la la mise
en route de de l'écriture du scénario ce
qui fait qu'en moins d'un an
pratiquement on a on a pu tourner le
film alors la femme Hélène la femme que
que vous incarnez vous la considérez
comment c'est la version féminine du
diable
euh je pense que c'est une version
féminine du diable mais je pense que ça
pourrait être aussi elle pourrait être à
un certain moment elle pourrait aussi
être un ange tout dépend des des
circonstances je pense que par exemple
si euh son mari John malkovic était en
danger à un certain moment elle aurait
pu devenir un ange à un certain moment
et le contraire aussi aurait pu se
passer je pense que nous sommes tous des
des anges ou des démons à certains
moment selon selon les circonstances
c'est auss votre avis John malkovic nous
sommes anges et démons à la
fois
tout mais j'attends toujours que mon
côté prenne le dessus je crois que c'est
tout à fait le cas vraiment vraiment
d'ailleurs les films que Manuel
fait bien
évidemmentr dans religion dans son
catholicisme
vousz tentation de
religion je crois ça ver très bien dans
le
film pashabitude finalement de tourner
AC desar international commeme mais
comme John malkovic est-ce qu'on n'est
pas un petit peu frustré il n'y a pas de
réelle face- àface entre entre vous deux
dans le film en tout cas pas de
face-àface direct est-ce que ça n'est
pas une une légère frustration euh je je
pense que ça peut être une frustration
pour des
d'éventuels spectateurs qui connaissent
pas du tout le cinéma de Manuel d'
Olivera ou qui sont pas prêts disons à
rentrer dans dans un film qui est quand
même l'œuvre d'un cinéaste avant tout il
y a pas d'affrontement parce que le film
est quand même d'Avord le film n'est pas
basé sur sur l'affrontement mais c'est
vrai nous sommes des compagnons
visiblement aussi des gens qui qui
vivent ensemble depuis assez longtemps
et c'est pour ça que'installe cette
relation qui est une une relation au
sang de gens qui vivent ensemble depuis
longtemps et qui sont habitués à ce jeu
elle se moque beaucoup de son mari parce
qu'elle pense je pense qu'il ne lui
accorde pas assez de temps lui est
habitué à C cette espèce de léger
sarcasme et l'ironie de sa femme il l'en
souffle mais en même temps il le
supporte parce que on sent que c'est une
relation
profonde John malkovic je crois que vous
habitez dans le midi de la France si je
me trompe c'est c'est
ça on a l'impression que vous êtes
totalement à l'écart de toute cette
frénésie qui entoure le festival de
Cann oui je crois qu'on on peut le dire
je suis un petit peu un outsider par
rapport à ce qui se passe à can c'est
vrai que je vis dans le sud très
tranquillement c'est
vrai mais ça me plaît de venir à can
tout de même quelques jours de jours
je crois qu'il y a quand même des choses
pires dans la vie que venir à Cann
Catherine denu c'est une coïncidence du
calendrier mais aujourd'hui est
également présenté le deuxème film de
Xavier Beauvois n'oublie pas que tu vas
mourir dans lequel joue votre fille Kara
mastroyani est-ce que vous avez vu le
film oui j'avais vu le film à Paris
avant qu'il soit totalement fini et je
savais que j'ai suis il y a très peu de
temps que le film serait en compétition
officielle pour représenter la France
mais comme j'avais vu le film et que moi
personnellement j'aime énormément le
film qui était un film assez dérangeant
mais très fort je savais que j'aurais
une certaine tension à l'idée que ma
fille allait quand même vivre ses
escaliers de canul pour la première fois
que ce serait quelque chose de difficile
mais en même temps j'avais vu le film et
j'étais quand même pas trop inquiète par
rapport à ça comment est-ce que l'on
juge la performance est-ce qu'on la juge
en tant que maèire ou en tant qu'actrice
en tant que professionnel euh je crois
que je lui parle comme une mère mais je
pense que je la je la juge si je peux la
juger en tous les cas comme une actrice
mais c'est vrai comme je la trouve
extrêmement séduisante je suis peut-être
un peu un peu partiale je vous remercie
infiniment de Neu merci beaucoup à John
malkovic vous allez donc monter les
marches ce soir une nouvelle fois pour
la présentation de ce film et je vous
propose donc de voir